[Música]
boa noite pessoal eu queria começar
falando um pouco de como que é
importante a gente ter acesso às coisas
e como que incomoda quando a gente não
tem acesso a alguma coisa que é do mesmo
jeito que comecei essa palestra de
costas pra vocês e o corpo incomoda de
não ter acesso a alguma coisa
o corpo incomoda quando a gente não
entende e quando só a parte que a gente
tem acesso a uma informação que a gente
pode começar a mudar nossa realidade
tem até uma brincadeira que eu faço
quando a gente fala de sonho que é
impossível ser humano ele não consegue
sonhar com algo que ele não conhece aqui
após que nenhum de vocês nunca sonhou
com alguém que nunca tinha visto os
nossos sonhos o nosso subconsciente a
gente sempre encontra alguém que a gente
já conhece alguém que já teve a
oportunidade de cruzar na nossa vida é
impossível a gente sonhar com alguém que
não conhece
falando em sonhos inclusive queria
agradecer a oportunidade de estar aqui
com você está pisando nele tapete
vermelho que eu sempre sonhei em me
apresento me apresentar uma peça do ted
mas eu só comecei a sonhar em me
apresentar uma peça do ted depois que eu
depois que eu conhecer a plataforma
enquanto não conhecer a plataforma não
tinha como vislumbrar ataque contando a
minha história pra vocês e agora sim
para me apresentar eu gosto me
apresentar como filho do meio da dona
alice não tem melhor maneira para me
apresentar e se define muito sou um ser
humano e seu filho do meio nem o mais
novo nenhuma esse velho e pra contar a
minha história pra contar pra falar o
que eu quero falar pra vocês contam um
pouco da minha história eu sou nascido e
criado no jardim pantanal que é uma
contém alguém tinha de passar aqui hoje
sempre tem alguém no jardim pantanal a
gente se espalha a gente está por todo
mundo e eu de fato não há como negar que
a maioria das pessoas conhecem pelo seu
histórico de enchentes e inundações são
é uma comunidade formada na década de 70
na década de 80 por famílias que vieram
do nordeste tentava em são paulo com a
família da minha mãe com uma família do
meu pai então bairro sem planejamento
bairro que foi sendo construído ali sem
nenhum tipo de planejamento sem nenhum
tipo de estrutura e hoje a deputada
inclusive tem esse nome por ficar assim
margens do rio tietê e por estar às
margens do rio tietê
como a gente viu lá na 4ª série na
outras ciências o rio precisa
transbordado precisa transbordar no
verão e isso faz com que a gente isso
fez com que a gente passa por diversas
enchentes por diversas inundações e o
que empreende hoje o que o transformou
hoje é justamente pra melhorar essa
realidade moradia que a empresa não tem
a função de acabar com as enchentes de
acabar com as inundações mas de lidar
com a grande problemática que é
ocasionada por isso também que só as
casas insalubres e eu lembro de uma
situação que eu tinha seis anos de idade
meu irmão mais novo tinha cinco anos de
idade
a gente passou por uma enchente tem
aquela piada que fala pobre não tem nada
mas quando a gente fala que perdeu tudo
é verdade acontece e foi pra gente
passou por uma dessas situações que eu
lembro da minha mãe tentando salvar os
móveis da minha mãe tentando colocar as
coisas em cima de tijolos
ela pegou e meu irmão colocou no lugar
mais alto de desculpa por aquilo como se
aquilo fosse culpa dela como se tivesse
desculpa por alguma coisa eu tinha seis
anos de idade não foi com seis anos de
idade que comecei a fazer alguma coisa
mas eu tenho certeza que é esse momento
que movimenta está fazendo o que estou
fazendo hoje porque a partir do momento
que eu passei por isso a partir do
momento que eu entendi que isso podiam
causar grande impacto na vida das
pessoas que a gente fala de uma
residência insalubres estação de uma
residência com mofo sem ventilação sem
iluminação com diversos problemas que
impactam negativamente na vida das
pessoas e como isso é prejudicial e aí
eu comecei eu não entendi isso eu
comecei empreender um sonho eu comecei a
aprender moradia digna que é um negócio
sério faz pequenas reformas nas
comunidades de baixa renda pra acabar
com os problemas que oferece uma solução
completa para a família para que ela
possa morar bem da sua própria casa
se uma pessoa não se sente bem da sua
própria casa onde mais ela vai sentir
bem e é por isso que a gente aprende
moradia digna
o grande propósito de empreender moradia
e eu só comecei a entender como eu poder
empreender uma moradia digna
quando eu entendi o que era desigualdade
social que não entende o que quero o meu
propósito e eu costumo falar que o
propósito é uma força que te leva a
transformação ea gente só consegue
começar a fazer essa transformação com a
gente encontra o nosso propósito
as pessoas costumam se confundir acham
que elas só podem trabalhar com um
propósito que elas só podem causar
impacto
se ela estivesse que elas só podem
causar o seu propósito estiverem
trabalhando com o impacto
necessariamente com o impacto social não
pessoal
a gente deve trabalhar com um propósito
em qualquer que seja a nossa carreira em
qualquer que seja a nossa função
em todas as funções a gente tem que
fazer com um propósito se a gente não
conseguisse identificar se a gente não
conseguir trabalhar com proposta já está
literalmente desperdiçando metade da
nossa vida
eu fiz essa conta das 16 horas a gente
passa acordado 8 horas a gente passa
entregando que a gente tem de mais
precioso que é o nosso tempo uma força
de trabalho uma organização para um
setor por uma empresa para uma ong
enfim se isso não está alinhado com o
que a gente viu fazer no mundo a gente
está literalmente gastando das 16 horas
8 horas metade expedição na nossa vida
por isso que é super importante a gente
descobrir qual é o nosso propósito se
alinhar com o nosso propósito e começará
a partir disso eu tenho uma grande amiga
que começando com a respeito disso ela
falou pra mim uma vez a confidenciou
para uma vez que quando ela sabia que
ele estava chuvoso que ele já está
nublado está cinza que a gente daria
tudo que o despertador toca a gente
daria tudo para ficar o restante do dia
ela costuma falar que quando está nesses
momentos ela pára e pensa se eu não
levantar da cama hoje a vida de quem vai
deixar de ser impactado
se eu não levantar da cama hoje a vida
de quem vai deixar de ser impactadas e
ela fala que ela não conseguia responder
pra si mesma ela começa a repensar a
carreira dela é ela começa a repensar o
que ela está fazendo da carreira dela
como ela tanto o propósito a carreira
dela e esse discurso pode parecer
simples esse discurso pode ser pode
parecer fácil pode parecer um dia para o
outro que a gente consegue alcançar esse
propósito a gente consegue alcançar isso
mas não é fácil pessoal
foi só quando eu entendi que a
desigualdade social era uma foi uma
descoberta na minha vida eu consegui o
meu propósito para causar essa
transformação e foi um processo
descobrir que desigualdade social é uma
descoberta ninguém ninguém nasce sabendo
que a desigualdade social porque
desigualdade social é delta pelo pela
pela denominação da palavra é delta é
quando você conhece
é uma realidade a escassez com essa
realidade de abundância você consegue
fazer o comparativo entre elas se você
só vive numa realidade escassez ou senão
você não consegue fazer o comparativo
que era realidade que eu vivia ao mesmo
tempo quem vive só uma realidade de
abundância não consegue fazer esse
comparativo
eu morava no jardim pantanal e graça
muito apoio da minha família graças a
muito muito esforço e muito estudo e
conseguir o acesso a um cursinho
pré-vestibular conseguir acesso à
universidade é conseguir uma bolsa do
prouni para cursar uma universidade
particular
eu estudei no mackenzie engenharia civil
uma 15 e foi quando conheci o que gera
desigualdade social porque eu quero
fazer um combinado com vocês inclusive
só pode falar mal do martins quem é
aluno mas quem não é ter um direito
então eu me coloco nesse papel
o que eu quero dizer com esse pessoal
que foi quando estudei numa das melhores
universidades que chega ao nosso país
mas ao mesmo tempo na verdade mais
burguesa e elitista que a gente tem
nosso país que descobriu que era
desigualdade social porque eu trabalhava
e morava no jardim pantanal estudava
numa quem trabalhava na vila olímpia no
metro quadrado mais caro da cidade de
são paulo ea nossa isso mesmo quem
comesse quem conhece a geografia de são
paulo sabe com essa logística difícil
mas eu sou eu disse que não me
incomodava não me incomodava ter que
acordar às três e meia da manhã e chegar
em casa à uma da manhã
o que me incomodava mesmo a viver
realidades tão diferentes todos os dias
era ter um ambiente tão próximos que não
está falando de 70 quilômetros de
distância falando de 40 km de distância
está falando de dois países diferentes
levando a mesma cidade diferenças tão
grandes da mesma cidade e foi aí que
descobriu que a desigualdade social ea
partir do momento que descobriu que era
desigualdade social que me caiu uma
ficha de que algo deveria ser feito em
frente a isso e que algo poderia ser
feito dentro de um problema que conhecia
muito bem dentro de um problema que além
de impactar muito impacta tanto a mim
como diversas outras pessoas porque a
educação que foi o que me deu acesso a
isso é a maior janela de oportunidade
que a população de baixa renda pode ter
pra quebrar esses mouros não dizer a
única mas com certeza maior e tem um
dado que acho super interessante pra
corroborar a tudo isso é que em um em
cada quatro jovens de do da classe média
entre 1 com quando a gente fala
nosso maior da maior porta de acesso à
universidade no nosso país que é o enem
durante fala da população de baixa renda
está falando de uma a cada 600
e por que eu trago esse dado pessoal
trago esse dado porque eu odeio quando
depois que a pessoa escuta uma história
que depois que a pessoa entende a minha
trajetória
quando ela principalmente ela me chama o
evento chama uma palestra
depois eu conto tudo que eu passei ela
me põe do lado dela me abraça e fala se
o matheus conseguiu porque os outros não
conseguem
eu quero me matar eu quero embora
falando entendeu nada do que eu falei
até agora porque na verdade pessoal e só
a construção de diversos privilégio que
eu tive na minha vida de ter nascido
homem na sociedade totalmente machista
de não ter tido que me preocupar com os
estudos a ter tido que me preocupar com
o trabalho até os meus 18 anos de idade
têm uma família que me sempre me apoiou
a estudar e depois trabalhar eu sou a
construção desses privilégios
privilégios que são pouquíssimos na
população de baixa renda e que por conta
disso por uma exceção da exceção da
exceção eu conseguir resultados moradia
já fez mais de 500 e formas morar
dignamente toda a zona leste de são
paulo
o nosso sonho grande está em todo brasil
começamos nossos primeiros testes no rio
de janeiro já faturamos mais de 2
milhões de reais para o governo
residências mais alugadas com as pessoas
de baixa renda
mas de novo foi só quando entendi que eu
podia usar os meus privilégios para
transformar desigualdade social que
comecei a trabalhar com isso e eu
costumo falar que depois dessa
descoberta eu não tinha o mais o direito
de continuar fazendo as coisas do jeito
que eu fazia
eu gosto muito de fazer uma referência
confirma aquela cena do filme matrix
inspirou matrix ou seja uma referência
ainda é pessoal e eu pergunto por que
cada vez mais ganha parece um público
mais jovem que ela tem uma galera com
mais de 18 anos que nosso filme matrix e
não era mais uma referência para eles
mas enfim aquele momento que uniu e
recebe as duas pílulas ele pode escolher
tomar pílula vermelha
vou esquecer tudo que ele viu tudo que
ele descobriu voltar para a realidade
dele ignorar aquilo para todo o sempre
hoje pode tomar a pílula azul ea partir
daí tomar pílula azul eu tenho ele não
vai mais conseguir viver da mesma
maneira que ele teve acesso àquele
conhecimento
eu queria que esse momento aqui agora
eu queria que essa
nesta o euro como o maior objetivo com
vocês aqui hoje é deixar isso muito
claro que a partir do momento que a
gente entende o que é a desigualdade
social
ninguém tem o direito de continuar
vivendo a mesma forma a gente pode fazer
acordo a partir de agora senão o pessoal
a partir do momento que a gente entende
a desigualdade social a partir do
momento que a gente entende que a gente
pode usar os nossos privilégios para
transformar essa desigualdade social
eu volto e conecta com aquilo que a
gente viu lá no início de sonho a gente
começa a sonhar com uma outra realidade
porque a gente só consegue sonhar com
que a gente conhece e se a gente não
conhece não tem como a gente eu vou
cobrar não tem como a gente especular
não tem como a gente vê nada
então o primeiro a gente entende que a
desigualdade social a gente pára pra
pensar quais são os nossos privilégios
ea partir desse privilégio começa a
sonhar com um modelo de sociedade muito
melhor que todos nós que estamos aqui eu
tenho certeza que escolheram tomar essa
segunda pílula de que não vai deixar de
que não vai se permite viver da mesma
forma a partir do momento que conhece
essa realidade porque eu tô cansado
pessoal tô cansado de construir pontes
que trouxe a gente constrói ponto quer
dizer que o muro ainda existe
quer dizer que ainda tem pessoas dos
dois lados do muro e eu tô cansada muito
trabalho construir pontes
eu tenho certeza absoluta que a nossa
energia vai ser muito melhor empregada
na hora que a gente começar a derrubar
os muros e eu conto com vocês para que a
gente comece e continuar fazendo isso
muito obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]
[Música]